nous sommes des animaux domestiques
je me souviens du premier jour d'école
stupeur et froid indicible je comprends
qu'il faut désormais rester assis sans
bouger sur une chaise toute la journée
et toutes les journées le mouvement
spontané devenait interdite la parole
était soumise à approbation contraindre
le corps et briser le mouvement naturel
et l'un des fondamentaux du dressage
nous avons été dressé nous sommes des
animaux domestiques
à partir de ce jour j'ai conçu une
passion sans limites pour la liberté
les atomes qui composent notre corps
sont les mêmes que ceux qui sont nés et
se sont développés avec l'univers
l'atome de carbone que vous expirez lors
de votre jogging en forêt qui est
absorbé par le brin d'herbe puis brouter
par le chevreuil qui sera ensuite
ingérés par un chasseur riverains de
votre parcours dominical
cet atome s'est baladé pendant quelques
milliards d'années avant de couler dans
votre sang et continuera de se promener
pendant quelques milliards de siècle
pourquoi brutalisé ses vertigineuses et
incessantes transformation et
contraindre ce flux de vie en conformité
tradition pensée correcte comportement
correct
pourquoi soumettre ce merveilleux et
irrépressible mouvement aux dogmes
religieux politique
comportementale et bien je ne sais pas
par contre je ne vois qu'un seul euro
med l'ivresse de la liberté l'amour de
l'autonomie la joie de l'émancipation au
détriment de la sécurité et du confort
pour illustrer mes propos je vais vous
relater une histoire familiale que je ne
racontais jusqu'à présent qu'à des amis
très proches
ma grand mère maternelle est né en 1913
dans une famille juive algérienne
analphabètes et excessivement pauvres il
habitait à 6 dans une écurie séparé des
chevaux par une simple cloisonnement
bois ils n'avaient ni accès direct à
l'eau ni vêtements décents en immobilier
et le père qui était cordonnier
n'arrivait pas à subvenir à leurs
besoins en nourriture ce qui pousse à ma
grand mère et ses soeurs à travailler
dès l'enfance
en parallèle de l'école malgré cet
environnement culturellement défavorisée
elle développe à très tôt un esprit
critique affûté et une rare autonomie de
pensée
de plus elle se révéla une petite fille
extrêmement doué pour les pour les
études et particulièrement pour les
mathématiques
si bien qu'elle fût encouragé à
continuer l'école
au delà du certificat d'études et devint
receveuse des postes rôle essentiel et
statut important en des temps où la
poste était le seul moyen de
communication
son oncle aaron menaça de la tuer
couteau sous la gorge
lorsqu'elle annonce à sa famille qu'elle
était athée et qu'elle allait se marier
un français non juifs
ma grand mère ne se soumit pas à ses
injonctions religieuses culturelles et
familiales et décida de faire sa vie
loin de ses valeurs qu'elle ne partage
et pas à l'époque il n'y avait pourtant
pas d'accès aux informations
alternatives internet n'existait pas il
n'avait ni télé ni radio qui aurait pu
être une ouverture sur le monde
alors si une enfant né au début du 20e
siècle sans jamais être sortie de son
tout petit village sans exposition à des
pensées différentes sans modèle
alternatif en inspirant puisque les
villageois qui l'entouraient sa famille
ses amis étaient tous soumis aux
traditions et à l'idéologie dominante
si cet enfant a pu s'émanciper alors
pourquoi pas n'importe qui à notre
époque
bien que n'ayant pas de réponse à cette
énigme
j'ai une ébauche d'explication ce qui
concerne ma grand mère je n'ai jamais
entendu ma grand mère se plaint dire que
sa situation était due à sa famille à
l'état à une société inique
je n'ai jamais entendu réclamé affirmé
que l'état lui de vettel droit faveur
réparation que la difficulté de sa vie
était dû au sexisme racisme et pourtant
elle y avait été confronté de manière
brutale notamment lors de la seconde
guerre mondiale où elle n'avait plus
droit d'exercer son métier de
fonctionnaire elle surmonter les
obstacles comme on résout un problème de
mathématiques en cherchant la solution
jamais jamais elle ne s'était conçu ni
perçu comme une victime et surtout elle
aimait la liberté plus que tout plus que
la tradition la sécurité du dogme le
confort de la famille
rien ni personne ne pouvait la dresser
car sa liberté n'était pas soumise aux
conditions c'était un élan impérieux et
inconditionnelle
alors voilà je suis venu avec mes
questions je pourrais évidemment vous
relatez mes tentatives
d'affranchissement les formes que prend
mon inconstante liberté le centre de
formation que j'ai fondée pour ceux qui
aspirent à développer leur autonomie
mais tout cela me paraît anecdotique
face à ces questions pourquoi nous
soumettons nous et pourquoi certains
s'épanouissent en dépit du monde tel
qu'il est je ne cherche pas ici a
suscité un débat car je sais qu'il est
impossible de convaincre un déterministe
qui pense sincèrement que l'échec est dû
à l'environnement car il y aura toujours
un facteur extérieur qui paraît
insurmontable
les parents l'éducation la génétique le
gouvernement la crise les finances
internationales l'injustice sociale
[Musique]
de même il est impossible impossible
d'empêcher un amoureux de la liberté de
croître
quelles que soient les circonstances car
le déterminisme n'existe pas pour l'être
humain libre
[Applaudissements]